our next speaker is a close friend and
also founder I've selected Everett Shah
from MIT
thank you so those are perfect talks
what I'm going to talk about today is
not as what I do at MIT but what we do
at a company I founded few years back
select so select when we started
actually we started with exactly the
question that both Brad and Avinash
raised is that when people come to your
store or people come to your website and
then they buy something or they look at
something but they what happened to the
things that that didn't buy or what
happened to the things that they browsed
and they decided not to consume them and
then we thought okay this is great there
is a signal that's left there there is
these are the things that are on display
and this is the things that I consumed I
purchased I liked so there's a
comparison that you have communicated
and so then the question is that given
this comparison is a signal can you
build interesting mathematical models
around it build algorithms at scale and
then derive signal out of it and there
was our view going in and there was the
I guess at least at that time my
optimism with which we started the
company and it was great because in the
process I learned at least that while I
teach machine learning to were
undergrads and grads right now at MIT in
the easiest department I think some of
the most interesting frontier or
goalposts for machine learning as we go
forward are actually coming from retail
it's like almost one would feel it is
for me getting five years back into this
space retail felt like the least sexy
thing to do but actually it is really
really fascinating so what I want to do
is that through this talk again it's a
very overview ish talk so I won't go
into the details of anything but
hopefully I will communicate some of the
challenges that I see that are out there
front and center they're already been
communicated in aspect by Brad and
Avinash and I'll just try to put them in
a specific context so again one way to
think about machine learning or a
popular buzzword now is AI
what would it do well it would take the
data and help us do decisions well and
if it's good to help us do that well
first let's make sure that we got data
in the right place for a past couple of
decades we got variety of different
software solutions even though data
might live in different silos unless
there are ways in which we can get them
in one place
you want to understand what your data
looks like that's where the
visualization revolution of last decade
there are all sorts of visualization
software is available but then the
question is that what do you do with it
well what do you do with this first
thing is what's going to happen next
there is now that I have this data
what's going to happen next what will be
the demand of a product tomorrow next
week next month once you understand that
the question is that well you want to
use that insight to make a decision and
then the question is what do you do with
it and you got lots of choices whether
the mind is going to go up should you
increase price the mind is going to grow
up should you stock more etc etc etc and
then once you figure out what to do with
it maybe you decided that you should
increase price or maybe you decided that
you should stock more which one was
better
again this was type of question one was
did it work and once you figured out
well here the solution here the
interventions if actually I put in place
sometimes it works sometimes it did not
work in question is can I evaluate it
and there's just too many things going
on so is there a way for me to isolate
it can I run experiments properly
finally once everything is put together
you just want to continue in loop and
this loop continues that different time
scale at different scale in terms of
geography and so on and so forth alright
so when we think from our machine
learning sense and we're when you're
teaching in class effect lis you look at
these three questions and you say well
the first question is nothing but
prediction problems so these are the
prediction problem in the most vanilla
form these are supervised learning
questions or maybe your semi-supervised
learning fuel labelled and lots of
unlabeled data or maybe actually the
data has unstructured information like
images or text so it's a first is your
extract features out of it and then use
that for the purpose of prediction so
those are the type of questions you
would ask for first task if you're
looking at this
can't ask really its decision-making
systems or what a good good formal way
to think about especially in the
environment where I sit at MIT some of
my colleagues have done some amazing
work at understanding Markov decision
processes and reinforcement learning so
these are the natural approaches or when
start thinking about just simple things
like model predictive control which is a
classical what control theorists are
thought about forever and so on or if
you think about understanding effect of
interventions it's the question of
causal inference like randomized control
is of course the one thing to do but
many times in retail we don't have
opportunity to do randomized control
right and I'll talk about that in a
second so maybe are there natural
experiments happening where are the
causality indices and so on again so all
of these three important things I think
come into play and retail I feel that in
each one of them are at the forefront
now at selective you spent time trying
to address question here so I'll spend a
good fraction of my time talking about
this because I understand that well and
have something to say here these are
however really really exciting challenge
and I will briefly point out few things
that I think are definitely worth
thinking about there hang in there there
exactly I will be echoing some of the
points that two earlier talks brought up
okay so with that just right prediction
is nothing but feature of past is
feature of future whether it's a
forecasting or whether it's missing
values did I say it right yeah I made
sure that I rehearsed it so that I don't
get in the wrong future of past this
feature of last week is feature of
tomorrow
[Laughter]
now again everybody whenever everybody
thinks about prediction right is always
about forecasts but it's not necessary
forecasts because it could be just
missing values
it's got to be static or it could be
dynamic and both aspects are important
and in the simplest form you got some
signature some observations some
features somehow you built a model and
you got your target and if you were
talking a couple of decades back maybe
demographics and my features I learned a
linear regression model to determine
what would be my life expectancy or if
I'm thinking of dynamics here then maybe
I've got noisy locations and I built a
beautiful Kalman filter or hidden Markov
model and that will give me the location
tracking system and fast forward it and
then I've got lots of images and then
I've got a beautiful neural network and
that will tell me whether it's a cat or
not or whether this digit is fire or
ditch this digit is 6 ok and these are
all terrific things and these are all
great things there's of course lots of
work that is along nonparametric
approaches and so on the thing is that
with all of these things you're thinking
about setting where I got lots of data I
mean to Train these kind of neural
networks I've got lots of images retail
is exactly the opposite in retail you
got extremely sparse data problem it's
like this is like saying that I've got a
billion coin tosses or million coin
tosses and I've got I gotta find bias of
ten coins retail is I've got million
coin tosses and I've got to find bias of
million coins and so that's the that's
the challenge putting your other way of
one way to look at the prediction
problem in retail is accurate demand
forecasting and by that I mean that's
when you take a product you take a
channel you take a time interval and you
tell me what is what is the demand of
this if you can do that well I think a
good fraction of retails retails data
science problem is solved of course it's
not as easy as I'm saying it's extremely
hard and that's the reason why this is a
massive
Challenge and one way to think about
this is again going back to the point I
made is it's about data is extremely
sparse there are two analogies I were to
give just to make the charr the point
home one is well this is a shirt that I
bought at some point from some store I
don't remember where but I bought it
this shirt in that stores or that
retailers inventory would have a certain
SKU number this shirt might have been
sold before that season but would have
been different SKU numbers just the way
things work so that means that the the
season it came out for sell we had no
before it came out we had no idea how
many of them are go to sell but what I
did have information as a retailer is a
well shirt like this where sold this
much now of course if I did not process
its text and image and few other things
we've very hard for me to figure out how
the information or past transaction will
give me any information maybe at the
categorical level I will say okay these
many shirts sell out this many jeans
okay and that won't be accurate enough
so that's one way to think about why
it's extremely sparse information and
unstructured information like text and
images can help other words you look at
is let's suppose we're still thinking of
selling gallons of milk and so there's
not really this kind of a problem in
that case I've got again while things
are selling a lot but you got whatever
you think all you got as
avinash nicely said it think of millions
or hundreds of millions of customer
depending on the type of retailer you
are and think of product depending on
the type of retailer you are you're
thinking of hundreds of thousands to
tens of millions to hundreds of millions
potentially that's the number all Mart
thinks about those many SKUs and now
I've got it's like an excel file with so
many columns and so many rows and now
look at I think of this as a white sheet
and put a black dot wherever for that
row in that column there's a transaction
that has happened now put it on this
sheet and it will look something like
this that's one way to say that it's
really really sparse and the question is
that how do you get around it that's the
that is there was a question and there
was a challenge well there's only one
solution there's no
there is no magic one here is somehow
you got a stitch information together
information together maybe through
products to their own structure
information across time across people
and across locations and if you manage
to stitch it well hopefully there is a
there is a way to do it now it select
what we do is that we help retailers
build solutions for a variety of
different things in particular things
like by optimization or assortment
planning fulfillment and there when
they're there their data is coming in
you can't you can't have a team of
engineers a team of data scientists re
starting from scratch because that way
we will never scale which means that one
way or the other you've got to build a
software a software that can do this
kind of things at scale in an automated
manner tomorrow and with some retailer
who has a Twitter feeds that come in and
say consume might that piece of
information as well well you've got to
have a staff software where you can sort
of just feed in that extra feed of data
and then hope that a prediction software
take care of it
one nice formalism for this kind of
problem is you can view the your data as
a higher order tensor so just here's a
caricature of that and this is as much
as any formal stuff I'll talk about in
this talk so let's think of this one
slice and one slice let's say here are
people and here are products and this is
information about transactions now the
same people and same product if you have
online blog maybe there's a browser
information maybe some more other things
you have maybe there are people whose
demographic information is that it's one
more slice maybe there are products
whose image and text information that
there are different slices and somehow
whatever orders I would have just fill
in this slice I don't care about other
slice but I want to use this other
slices to put this together now if I
view this as this has a tensor with
lower dimensional latent representation
hopefully I can get something out of it
and that's exactly the software that we
have built and since this type of
outcomes are
by people people don't like to be told
right they need to be explained and so
what we do is that we for every
prediction we make we provide some form
of provenance one way to think about
what sort of provenance look say well
I'm telling you that this sure is going
to sell ten times because similar shirt
like this last year sold nine times and
there is an upward trend so I thought
each layer is like I said fraud of
people and products and then the
different layers are primarily location
but you're also saying is online so
again it's not adjusted I'm drawing it
as if it's a three order tensor but we
think of as a higher order tensor
all right so there was a yes of course
to fill out the demand curve across
price price elasticity again so that's
extremely hard because especially with
most retailer and what you have is that
most to and if you're really really
lucky three price point I listen our
experience so what helps yes so that is
an important thing we already do one way
you can think about is why this kind of
approach helps and maybe you can get a
little more technical later is that it
is a product like this there was sold at
fifty dollars I don't know how about
let's say fifty dollars and here is
another shirt which is somewhat similar
not exactly same but somewhat similar
which is sold at forty five dollars and
this shirt was solid fifty dollars in
San Francisco maybe in now I think a new
new Berkeley our new Oakland which is
getting closer to San Francisco the
other shirt was sold at forty five
dollars and now I got this natural
experiment that just happened and now I
get a sort of a more data about products
price elasticity in a sense than what I
was doing before and that is happening
because I'm going across in some sense
excellent point and having it actually
helps a lot it's a it's remarkable that
how much
all right so in maybe remaining three
minutes I'll very quickly talk about two
other things and again as I mentioned
most of our time at least I'd select
we've spent building this software and
that's what we commercialized and that's
what we sell in even in now federal
government these are the very adjacent
extremely important questions and I feel
they need a lot of attention and as to
off earlier speakers I said this is
extremely important all right so quickly
decision-making systems any point of
time you got you made prior his history
of decisions you got your state of the
system and you want to decide where is
the next action you want to be okay and
then continue repeating there's a
classical way and maybe there's a modern
ways to think about it
again here where you're thinking of
training a goal you've got lots of data
now forget alphago zero for a second
because then the rules are very simple
at the end of the day but if you think
about alphago then it was a lots of data
that you had and then you trained it now
you don't have this much amount of data
again to train yourself in a setting of
retail and also the number of options
here a few the number of options that
you haven't retailer are just infinite
in some sense right
for example thinking from life lifecycle
of a product at some point it's
manufactures if I get is manufacture for
Dively come to retailer at some point
you're deciding how much money you want
to spend where you want to spend that
first decision once you decided how very
you how much money you're going to spend
somebody has to decide what products to
buy once you've decided what products
you buy you will decide where to ship in
terms of DC's once you have ship in DC's
you want to decide how do you allocate
it a little shorter time scale once
you've located maybe it's not it's not
selling either you liquidate or you
fulfill or you transfer and then the
cycle continues and all of these
decisions are happening at different
time scales and there's just too many
options that just makes it really hard
so I don't know even how to think about
this in a holistic manner the
only hope is that even if we get
something like simple MPC working I
think that'll be huge success and one
thing that we should never ignore in
this world is that whatever MPC solution
or whatever solution comes out humans
are going to be involved in the loop and
you want to make sure that it you man
understands understand accept or work
with that rather than not and again
those things naturally came out in
earlier talks as well so and finally in
coming to causality I think this is this
is an excellent thing that sort of we
came across in all our helping with our
all clients where you say I'm going to
change how you allocate things in these
three stores and then water goes by and
they say well we say well revenue went
up I said look at this because of us he
said well I don't know actually revenue
went up because he konami became better
I said no no it wasn't because of us or
I mean you went I said no it was not
because of us he went down and so so
what do you do well this is a classical
situation where you can't do randomized
control or you don't have really you're
not studying the brain where is the
monkey is picking up instead of your
spiked neuronal spikes are going up or
down you need either you need something
like natural experiments just the way
there's a interesting thing going on and
trying to say that well gender gap sorry
the gender wage gap is not because of
the discrimination but because of women
having women becoming mother and that's
a question but that's one way to try to
understand how we can do that in the
retail context like a synthetic control
seems like a natural thing to type to
answer the type of question I raised
earlier that is is here three stores
that I change here are ten other stores
which almost look like these three
representative stores see what happened
to them don't change any policies for
them but change policies for these and
then do control and then sort of try to
answer that question but again that's
just one type of problem there are many
such things so
I feel it's almost like a crisper for
genetics crisp if you know crisper you
can throw actually go in and gin each
knock out each of the DNA piece very
nice anyways so I think it really is
amazing at an amazing stage and now that
sort of data is coming getting in a much
better way everybody's open about it so
if I were to talk about where are the
next sets of goal posts for much for
machine learning I think retail is
definitely a candidate all right that
means amazing we are surviving and
growing more importantly as far as
clients are concerned primarily
retailers but in the in the retail
brands like think of Urban Outfitters
which is that you separated prediction
decision-making causality but the
reality is that the types of predictions
you're making I mean one of the reasons
the data is sparse is because you're
trying to understand actions that
haven't been taken yet like prices are
just you know some of the other
assortments or something and if you did
you wanna understand the impact than the
counterfactual absolutely so yeah it's
interesting to think about where the
lines flirt between machine learning and
then and then building building like the
decision-making system
okay great last speaker is Andrew
Goldberg and he's gonna talk to us about
north efficiency okay so I'm gonna burn
metals on this sorry